Last year, the town of Celeron,
New York was accosted
by a monstrous, gobbler-of-souls
Lucille Ball tribute statue,
which the townspeople
quickly named "Scary Lucy."
-Aah! Aah!
-STELLING: Aah! Scary.
(laughter)
Let me perform
in the club with you, Ricky.
(laughter)
Aah!
Now you may remember
that we launched
to bring Scary Lucy here
to the @midnight stage,
which, coincidentally, is where
I Love Lucy was filmed.
There first few seasons
of I Love Lucy
-were filmed right here.
-Right here.
I feel like we are...
100% living up
(laughing): to the comedy legacy
of the show.
I can't even say it
with a straight face.
I can't even say that
Anyway, one of our fans
put this sign on her.
Uh, "Let @midnight
have this statue."
"Bring Lucy home"
was the hashtag.
We sent two of our guys
over there.
They went
to a town hall meeting.
They were like,
"Can we have that?"
-(laughter) -"Can we have
that horrifying thing
that you can't
do anything with?"
And they were like,
"Hmm, (bleep) off."
-(laughter)
-It's now a year later.
They finally replaced Scary Lucy
with this new beautiful statue.
This is Botox Lucy.
(laughter)
-I don't know if I like it.
-STELLING: It's better.
-(applause and cheering)
-I don't...
I get the feeling
that Botox Lucy
is the kind of lady who would
body-shame Scary Lucy.
It kind of feels like
there's a...
-Ugh.
-(laughter)
They captured the feeling
of what it was like
to be married to Desi, I think,
that's what happened.
-(laughter, groaning, applause)
-HARDWICK: Possibly so.
Possibly so.
That's a...
that's an historic burn.
HARDWICK:
Now since
we tried to get the statue
from Celeron,
and they wouldn't give it to us,
what can the horrifying Scary
Lucy statue be used for now?
-Beth.
-Tim Burton's fluffer.
-HARDWICK: Yes. Points.
-(laughter, applause)
HARDWICK:
Hari.
-Larry King's next wife.
-(laughter)
(applause)
HARDWICK:
Jason.
Uh, drill a hole in its mouth.
I'll take it.
-HARDWICK: All right, points.
-Uh, no.